Rusia, Rusia y más Rusia.
Así ha sido el bombardeo de noticias internacionales
desde que las hordas de Putin invadieran Ucrania
en febrero de 2022.
La Guerra de Ucrania ha acaparado prácticamente
toda la atención mediática y política a
nivel internacional.
Y es lógico.
Digamos que la guerra de Ucrania ha tapado
lógicamente todo lo demás.
Incluyendo otros eventos también trágicos.
Por ejemplo, ¿recordáis estas imágenes
de 2021?
Efectivamente, queridos amigos, en agosto
de 2021, con la retirada de las últimas tropas
de Estados Unidos, Afganistán volvió a caer
en manos del fundamentalismo islámico: Afganistán
cayó otra vez en manos de los talibanes.
Y ya sé lo que muchos me vais a decir: ¿pero
vamos a ver Alberto, no nos contasteis ya
toda esta historia?
Pues sí, es cierto…
En 2021 aquí en Visualpolitik publicamos
una trilogía para contaros por qué los talibanes
tuvieron tanto éxito y qué podría significar
su regreso.
Si no los visteis os dejamos los links en
la descripción.
El caso es que prácticamente 2 años de gobierno
talibán después, hemos querido preparar
un nuevo vídeo para contaros cómo está
siendo el nuevo gobierno y qué ha supuesto,
exactamente, el regreso de los talibanes al
poder.
Aunque creo que con noticias como esta ya
sabéis por donde van los tiros.
N1(Los niños afganos mueren de hambre a medida
que el hambre “se extiende rápidamente”.
RFERL)
(El hambre y la pobreza siguen acechando a
los desesperados afganos.
La falta de financiación golpea a la maltrecha
economía afgana, provocando un aumento de
la pobreza.
Aljazeera)
Efectivamente, Afganistán está pasando por
una de sus peores crisis de todos los tiempos
y la ayuda humanitaria, pues…
Simplemente, ya no llega como ocurría antes
de los talibanes.
Pero, no solo eso, la destrucción de prácticamente
todas libertades individuales, el haber convertido
a este país de nuevo en un refugio de grupos
radicales y su particular forma de gobernar,
despótica y anacrónica están haciendo que
Afganistán dispute la competición por convertirse
en el peor país del mundo.
Pero, queridos amigos, amigas, ¿cómo han
llegado los talibanes hasta aquí?
¿De qué forma están gobernando exactamente
Afganistán?
¿Está siendo el gobierno tan desastroso
como muchos señalan o por contra están aprendiendo
a llevar las riendas del país?
¿Quiénes están cortejando hoy a los talibanes?
Pues bien, en este vídeo os vamos a responder
a todas estas preguntas.
Y ya os adelanto que muchas respuestas, seguro
os van a sorprender…
O quizás no.
Arranquemos.
T1(TALIBÁN 1.0)
Seguro que muchos, si no la gran mayoría,
pensaréis que los talibanes no son más que
una panda de zumbados con ansias de poder.
Y, en cierto modo, puede que así sea.
Pero, ¿sabéis de dónde salieron?
¿Os suena de algo la palabra “muyahidín”?
Pues los talibanes comenzaron siendo muyahidines,
es decir, en términos estrictos, combatientes
islamistas que hacen la yihad.
Sin embargo, normalmente, cuando nos hablan
de muyahidines, muchos automáticamente seguro
que pensamos en aquellos afganos apoyados
por Estados Unidos que lucharon contra la
Unión Soviética cuando esta invadió Afganistán
en 1979.
Claro que, después de la retirada soviética,
los muyahidines hicieron estallar una especie
de guerra civil entre 1992 y 1996.
De ese conflicto nacieron los talibanes, quienes,
por cierto, ganaron la guerra.
Y así, queridos amigos, nació en 1996 el
primer gobierno talibán.
(El primer gobierno talibán ha sido considerado
como uno de los más brutales de la historia
reciente.
Los derechos humanos eran constantemente pisoteados:
Ejecuciones públicas en campos de fútbol,
lapidación de mujeres por adulterio y castigos
inhumanos por simplemente mostrar alguna mínima
parte del cuerpo femenino.
Por supuesto, cualquier derecho o libertad
individual para las mujeres fue borrado del
mapa.
Se las privó de la educación, de tener un
empleo e, incluso, de poder desplazarse si
no no era con un hombre de su círculo.
Todo un infierno.
El régimen era tan brutal que solamente era
reconocido por tres países en todo el mundo:
Pakistán, Arabia Saudí y los Emiratos Árabes
Unidos.
El régimen terminó cayendo 5 años después
de hacerse con el poder.
Claro que no cayó por ninguna revuelta social,
sino por la intervención del Tío Sam.
Como todos sabéis, tras los atentados del
11-S Estados Unidos puso en su mira a los
talibanes por haber hecho de Afganistán un
espacio seguro para grupos terroristas como
la Al-Qaeda de Bin Laden.
Washington exigió la entrega de los líderes
de Al-Qaeda y como los talibanes se negaron,
en octubre de ese mismo año, las tropas norteamericanas
invadieron el país.
El primer gobierno talibán era historia.)
Sin embargo, como decimos en España: hierba
mala nunca muere.
Y eso, eso es exactamente lo que pasó con
los talibanes.
A pesar del control aplastante de Estados
Unidos durante los primeros años, en 2005
los talibanes comenzaron a reagruparse y en
2006 ya empezaron a desarrollar operaciones
de cierta envergadura contra las tropas estadounidenses.
A partir de entonces, y con el apoyo del gobierno
de Pakistán, poco a poco la presencia y la
influencia de los talibanes se fue extendiendo
por la mayor parte del país.
Además, gracias a los altos ingresos derivados
del comercio de Opio, los talibanes lograron
convertirse en la insurgencia mejor financiada,
armada y organizada.
La insurgencia perfecta y toda una pesadilla
para Washington.
La férrea resistencia Talibán y los escasos
avances tanto del gobierno como de los propios
militares afganos, hicieron que el entonces
presidente Donald Trump tomara una decisión
que copó todos los titulares internacionales
en 2020.
Fijaos.
N3(Conflicto afgano: Estados Unidos y los
talibanes firman un acuerdo para poner fin
a 18 años de guerra.
BBC)
Efectivamente, sin la participación del gobierno
de Afganistán, Trump llegó a un acuerdo
con los talibanes: prometió retirar todas
las tropas de Estados Unidos para el verano
de 2021.
A cambio, los talibanes debían comprometerse
a que Afganistán no se convirtiera en un
nido de grupos terroristas internacionales
que pudieran amenazar a Estados Unidos y sus
aliados.
El segundo gobierno talibán en Afganistán
estaba ya en marcha.
Y.
amigos, eso es exactamente lo que ocurrió
en 2021…
De forma mucho más rápida de lo que nadie
hubiera previsto.
Tras la salida de las tropas norteamericanas,
el ejército afgano prácticamente se deshizo
y los talibanes volvieron a tomar Kabul.
Desde entonces, este país desapareció de
los grandes medios de comunicación.
Pero, ¿qué ha ocurrido desde entonces?
¿Cómo es el nuevo Afganistán de los talibanes?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T2(TALIBANES…
VERSIÓN ACTUALIZADA)
Seamos honestos, cualquiera con un poco de
sentido común sabía que los talibanes iban
a seguir un recorrido más o menos similar
al de su primer gobierno.
Es cierto que esta vez se han intentado mostrar
como algo más moderados, pero los datos son
los datos, y la realidad es que este Afganistán
talibán se ha convertido nuevamente en un
infierno en la tierra.
Aunque para unos más que para otros:
N4(Afganistán: Los talibanes prohíben el
acceso de las mujeres a las universidades
en medio de la condena internacional.
BBC)
(Los talibanes prohíben a las mujeres afganas
trabajar con Naciones Unidas.
LeMonde)
Exacto, mis queridos seguidores de VisualPolitik,
los talibanes han hecho justo lo que todos
esperábamos: se han vuelto a cargar de un
plumazo prácticamente todos los derechos
y libertades de las mujeres.
No pueden estudiar en las universidades ni
las adolescentes en institutos.
Tampoco pueden trabajar en ONGs ni en las
agencias de las Naciones Unidas.
Y, no solo eso, en las empresas en las que
tengan permitido trabajar, que cada vez son
menos, solo pueden hacerlo si están completamente
separadas de los hombres.
Y, por supuesto, si no cumplen con el estricto
código de vestimenta, pueden esperarse lo
peor.
Todo ello por cortesía del restablecido Ministerio
de la Propagación de la Virtud y la Prevención
del Vicio, que es el que los talibanes han
puesto en sustitución del Ministerio de la
Mujer que había hasta su llegada.
Y ahí no termina todo.
Junto a las mujeres, los tayikos, que son
las voces más críticas con los talibanes
y el segundo grupo étnico más grande del
país después de los pastunes - a los cuales,
por cierto, pertenecen la mayoría de los
talibanes - también están siendo duramente
reprimidos.
Redadas, allanamientos, detenciones arbitrarias,
palizas y desapariciones, además de asesinatos
extrajudiciales, han plagado de miedo a los
tayikos y prácticamente a cualquiera que
se atreva a criticar al régimen talibán.
Por supuesto, como os podéis imaginar, la
libertad de expresión brilla por su ausencia.
Pero no solo eso: ¿recordáis el trato de
Trump con los talibanes?
Sí, eso de que no convertirían a Afganistán
otra vez en un nido de terroristas.
Pues, vosotros mismos…
N6(Según un experto, Afganistán vuelve a
ser un refugio para los terroristas, ya que
la capacidad de EE.UU. "sobre el horizonte"
se enfrenta a limitaciones.
Fox News)
Efectivamente, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
grupos como Al-Qaeda o los talibanes pakistaníes
conocidos como el TTP, ahora campan a sus
anchas por todo el país.
De hecho, ¿sabéis dónde fue asesinado el
líder de Al-Qaeda, Ayman al-Zawahiri, en
el verano del 2022?
Pues ni más ni menos que en el mismísimo
centro de Kabul, la capital afgana.
N7(2 agosto, 2022: Muere el líder de Al Qaeda
Ayman al Zawahiri.
Estados Unidos afirma que un ataque con drones
de la CIA ha matado al líder de Al Qaeda,
Ayman al Zawahiri, en Kabul, la capital de
Afganistán, en el mayor golpe al grupo desde
la muerte de su fundador, Osama bin Laden,
en 2011.
AlJazeera)
Aunque bueno, es cierto que los talibanes
al menos sí están combatiendo al Estado
Islámico de Jorasán, la organización que
atentó en el aeropuerto de Kabul cuando las
tropas de Estados Unidos se estaban retirando
y que acabó con la vida de una docena de
soldados americanos y 150 afganos.
Pero, seamos honestos, este enfrentamiento
no tiene nada que ver con el acuerdo con Trump.
Sino con las hostilidades que existen entre
ambos grupos.
Vamos, una lucha de poder.
Sin embargo, pese a todas las atrocidades,
muchos analistas también dicen estar muy
sorprendidos con algunos aspectos de la gestión
económica de los talibanes.
(Después del shock económico inicial, los
talibanes han conseguido manejar y estabilizar
la economía del país.
Por ejemplo: han conseguido recuperar en cierto
modo el valor que la moneda nacional, el Afgani,
tenía antes del aislamiento internacional
mediante un control más férreo de los dólares
que salen del país.
Además, según el Banco Mundial, la corrupción
en las aduanas ha caído de un 62% a un 8%
debido a los graves castigos que la “sharía”
o ley islámica impone: roba y te cortamos
una mano.
También han conseguido los ingresos suficientes
como para poder pagarle el sueldo a los 800.000
empleados públicos del país, entre ellos
a 150.000 soldados y 200.000 policías.)
Incluso se están permitiendo el lujo de poner
en marcha algunos proyectos grandes.
N8(Los talibanes están cavando un enorme
canal.
Un megaproyecto en el norte de Afganistán
corre el riesgo de aumentar las tensiones
regionales.
The Economist)
Por supuesto, todo esto no son más que apuntes
en el margen.
¿Pensáis que la situación del país permite
ser optimistas?
Pues, como os podéis imaginar, nada más
lejos de la realidad.
Después de que los talibanes llegaran al
poder, el país quedó totalmente aislado,
además de sufrir un montón de sanciones.
Entre 2021 y 2022 la economía cayó un 35%,
llevándose por delante cientos de miles de
empleos y destruyendo la mayor parte del pequeño
tejido productivo del país.
Esto, como ya os podéis imaginar, está llevando
al límite a la sociedad afgana: según la
ONU el 97% de la población vive en pobreza
y el número de afganos que necesitan ayuda
humanitaria ha pasado de unos 6 millones en
2019 a 28 millones en la actualidad.
Esto ha hecho que la hambruna se esté apoderando
rápidamente de Afganistán.
Y eso a pesar de la ayuda humanitaria enviada
por la ONU, Estados Unidos, la Unión Europea
y otros actores internacionales.
Y, claro, con semejante panorama no resulta
extraño que los talibanes estén buscando
rápidamente una solución, lo que pasa primero
por intentar ser reconocidos a nivel internacional
para así poder conseguir cierta estabilidad
y normalidad.
Pero, ¿creéis que hay algún estado que
lo quiera reconocer?
Pues, ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
T3(EL RECONOCIMIENTO, EL GRAN RETO TALIBÁN)
Ya os hemos contado que en los años 90 solo
3 países reconocieron el gobierno talibán.
Pues bien, ¿sabéis cuántos países les
han reconocido en este segundo periodo?
La cantidad total de 0.
0 países.
Efectivamente, queridos seguidores de VisualPolitik,
esta vez ni la propia Pakistán les ha querido
reconocer por ahora.
Y eso que los han estado apoyando casi desde
su nacimiento.
Pero esta vez las cosas son diferentes: cerca
de dos años después de regresar al poder,
ni sus socios más cercanos confían en ellos.
Por ejemplo, cojamos el caso de Pakistán.
Pakistán tiene varios problemas con este
Afganistán talibán, empezando por el apoyo
que la India les está brindando…
Lo que lógicamente no está sentando nada
bien en Islamabad.
Con todo, probablemente es el conflicto fronterizo
por la denominada “línea Durand” lo que
más tensiones esté generando entre ambos
países.
Esta línea, que es la que separa a los dos
países, fue establecida por el Imperio Británico
en 1893, y desde la independencia de ambos
países ha sido una constante fuente de tensión.
De hecho, los enfrentamientos entre las tropas
fronterizas de ambos países no son algo extraño.
Sin embargo, parece que las cosas se están
calmando.
N9(8 de mayo 2023: Pakistán y Afganistán
acuerdan impulsar el comercio y rebajar las
tensiones fronterizas.
Al-Jazeera)
Claro que no vayamos tan rápido.
Hay un asunto que no solo es un impedimento
para que Pakistán reconozca a los talibanes,
sino que también lo es para dos de los actores
regionales y mundiales más importantes: China
y Rusia.
(Ya sea Pakistán, China o Rusia, los tres
países tienen algo en común: su preocupación
por la seguridad nacional y regional.
En este sentido, por ejemplo, Pakistán ha
acusado a los talibanes afganos de darles
un espacio seguro a los talibanes pakistaníes,
quienes rompieron el alto al fuego con el
gobierno pakistaní el 28 de noviembre del
2022 y que ya han atentado en ciudades importantes
del país, como Peshawar o Karachi, matando
a docenas de personas.
Por su lado, China tiene una preocupación
similar, pero en este caso con el Movimiento
Islámico del Turquestán Oriental, que está
formado por fundamentalistas islámicos de
la etnia uigur que concentra su actividad
en la Región Autónoma de Xinjiang que, precisamente,
hace frontera con Afganistán.
De esta forma, China teme que los talibanes
hagan de su país un espacio seguro para los
militantes uigures y por eso exige que Kabul
siga entregando a los que capture como ya
venía haciendo el anterior gobierno afgano.
Sin embargo, los talibanes ya han dejado libres
a varios de ellos, lo que en Pekín no ha
sentado demasiado bien.)
En este sentido, Rusia es el país menos preocupado
de los tres, ya que su mayor amenaza, el Estado
Islámico de Khorasan o ISIS-K —que ha comenzado
una campaña anti-Rusia— está siendo combatido
por los talibanes en suelo afgano.
Sin embargo, ni la propia Rusia ha reconocido
aún a los talibanes como los legítimos gobernantes
de Afganistán.
Claro que eso no significa que no se haya
acercado ya a ellos.
De hecho, Rusia ha sido el primer Estado en
cerrar un acuerdo de esta magnitud con los
talibanes:
N10(Los talibanes firman un acuerdo con Rusia
para vender petróleo, gas y trigo a bajo
precio.
Bloomberg)
Y lo cierto es que China tampoco se está
quedando atrás.
Ha levantado el 98% de los aranceles para
los productos afganos y ha comenzado a dar
visados a empresarios de este país.
Y no solo eso, a pesar de las escasas infraestructuras
que hay en Afganistán, el año pasado también
aprobó una inversión de $216 millones para
construir un parque industrial a las afueras
de Kabul.
Además, ¿qué queréis que os diga?
Que China, Rusia o Pakistán terminaran reconociendo
al gobierno talibán no sería ninguna sorpresa.
Digamos que no suelen llevarse muy bien con
las normas impuestas por Occidente.
Y por eso ya han dado algunos pasos en esa
dirección: la de reconocer a los talibanes.
Claro que, sin garantías de seguridad y cooperación
creíbles, esto también está en el aire.
Y lo cierto es que tampoco cambiaría gran
cosa.
Lo diferente sería que Estados Unidos o la
Unión Europea los reconociera.
Y, lo creáis o no, muchos analistas americanos
ya lo están pidiendo.
¿La razón?
Pues la de siempre: poder influir hasta cierto
punto en la deriva del gobierno talibán y
del país.
C1(“Estados Unidos debería reconocer diplomáticamente
al gobierno talibán de Afganistán.
No es fácil para (mi) decirlo como exembajador
afgano (…). Hacerlo será percibido como
una dolorosa traición para muchos, pero la
alternativa – permitir el peligroso descenso
de Afganistán a un reino ermitaño y renunciar
a la perspicacia y a los medios para influir
en los acontecimientos – serían consecuencias
más nefastas para todos” – Javid Ahmed,
exembajador afgano en un artículo de Foreign
Policy, 2023.)
Al igual que este embajador, muchos analistas
creen que ni las sanciones ni ninguna otra
forma de coerción va a hacer que los talibanes
cedan en su empeño de seguir violando los
Derechos Humanos, y que lo mejor que puede
hacer Estados Unidos en este momento es reconocerlo
antes que ningún otro país para intentar
hacer de Afganistán un lugar menos hostil.
Este es el debate.
En cualquier caso, para hacerlo, primero tendría
que haber alguna certeza de que los talibanes
escucharan las recomendaciones estadounidenses,
algo que, no nos engañemos, parece muy improbable.
De momento, Biden no ha dado señales de que
vaya a reconocer a los talibanes, lo que supone
un duro golpe para un Afganistán que está
pasando por uno de los peores momentos de
su historia.
Dicho esto la pregunta es para todos vosotros:
¿creéis que Biden debería reconocer a los
talibanes?
¿Podría hacerlo Trump si volviera a la presidencia
en 2024?
¿Cuál creéis que será el primer Estado
en reconocerlos?
¿Será Rusia la primera para formar una hermandad
de Estados paria?
¿China?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí en VisualPolitik
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas,
así que suscribíos a este canal y dadle
a la campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un saludo y hasta pronto.